Do you have any articles about the relationship between hypothyroid, liver function, and hormones?
When you add in cortisol and ademia, it seems very hard to figure out what is causing
which thing, but they can all affect cancer.
Yeah, I don't know if there's any articles or research, if that's what you're asking, about the
connection with all those things with cancer, for sure. If you go on the chronic disease in autoimmune
course, module six is all about thyroid, that may be helpful to you. As far as liver function
and hormones, there's probably lots of data out there. I don't know the direct correlation
with as far as estrogen and progesterone testosterone with liver function. As far as cortisol levels
and ademia, I think the only correlation with that is symptoms. If you have really low cortisol,
really low function, adrenal, it can give you the same symptoms as anemia. Having to differentiate
what my symptoms are coming from is the issue there. Then added in the whole picture of cancer.
Again, one of the things I've always said is that you look at subjective data when you're looking at
whether my cancer is getting worse or better, and one of the most common things that you're going to see
subjectively with cancer, besides possibly pain, but many times many cancers don't produce pain.
That would be more in like colorectal cancer, or pancreatic cancer, or maybe prostate cancer,
but more so would be fatigue. If your fatigue is long-lasting fatigue, that can be a clue that
your cancer could be worsening. Why would a person with cancer get fatigue? It's not just
magically you get tired because your cancer is growing. If the cancer is growing, it can cause
anemia, and therefore give you fatigue. Unless your cancer is on your adrenal glands, or affecting
your adrenal glands directly, it's not going to cause cancer. It's typically not going to cause
low adrenals. The cancer is typically not going to affect cortisol levels directly.
How would you measure that then? Objectively, you look at a CBC and you would see if you have anemia
or not. Now, if you have a CBC and you have a history of anemia, that's a historical thing.
And then your subjective findings are getting worse. If your anemia and you can look at past
blood work, and your anemia hasn't worsened at all, then you have to look at other causes. Is it
hormonal? Is it adrenal? Is it pituitary? Is it thyroid? So yeah, you do it to look at other causes.
Now, I realize that very few people have cancer as an island in itself. You have multiple
cold morbidities that you do want to deal with if you can. So you are finding the
bandlet multiple fronts when you're dealing with any disease. So it does become challenging
to say the least. And you just have to kind of fight your way through those muddy waters
to get to that level of feeling as best as you possibly can.